Liegt der warp antrieb in greifbarer nähe also hat, er, eine chance realisiert zu werden eine voraussetzung
Dafür ist dass wir negative. Masse erzeugen. Und genau das ist gelungen die fachwelt träumt jetzt schon von neuartigen laser in supercomputern
Und eben sogar einen warp antrieb ist das tatsächlich realistisch. Und wie genau lässt sich negative. Masse erzeugen klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Danke für den themenvorschlag über whatsapp wie er da dabei sein könnt und themen vorschlagen kommt
Und vor allem die unzuverlässige abo box von youtube überlistet das erfahrt. Ihr am ende des videos
Mehr als klar ist dass sich. Ein objekt wie beispielsweise
Einen fußball den, wir anstoßen sich tatsächlich auch nach vorne weg aktion, gleich reaktion oder dass
Ein wassertropfen aus dem wasserhahn nach unten fällt. Und nicht nach. Oben das alles lernen wir schon wenn wir noch sehr
Klein, sind bei negativer, masse ist das anders hier gilt unser grundsatz der alltagswelt nicht mehr denn wenn, man
Sie anstößt bewegt sie, sich in die entgegengesetzte richtung sie beschleunigt also rückwärts wenn, man
Einen fußball anstupsen würde würde er sich auf einen zu bewegen negative, masse zu erzeugen das war lange
Ein traum der wissenschaftswelt und es ist tatsächlich. Das erste mal gelungen
notwendig dafür ist
Aufwendige kühltechnik rubidium atome wurden auf wenige bruchteile eines grades über dem absoluten nullpunkt von minus
273 15 grad celsius abgekühlt. Und zwar mit hilfe eines lesers dieser
Aggregatzustand wird als bose einstein. Kondensat bezeichnet die materie verhält sich da nicht
So wie einzelne teilchen sondern wie ein einziges atom. Und eher wie eine welle doch immer
Noch, besitzt sie eine normale positive. Masse vereinfacht gesagt wurden die atome dann durch gezielte manipulation mit einem laser geschüttelt
Und sie veränderten ihre bewegung das nennt sich spin bahn. Kopplung und schon bewegen
Sich die rubidium atome nicht die die richtung in die man. Sie geschubst hat sondern die
Entgegengesetzte die materie fällt sich also, so als hätte sie eine negative
masse sie beschleunigt rückwärts dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
Michael fox es sieht aus als wenn das rubidium gegen eine. Unsichtbare mauer
Stoßen würde das forschungsteam vermutet dass negative masse nicht nur im labor sondern auch natürlich
vorkommen ran beispielsweise in neutronensternen
Oder schwarzen löchern oder bei der rätselhaften dunklen energie also wirklich nur unter extremen bedingungen
Wir hatten ja schon, mal über dieses thema berichtet aber jetzt. Kommen doch was da zu einem
Anderen us amerikanischen forschungsteam ist ein weiterer
Schritt gelungen sie haben quasi teilchen erzeugt die sich so verhalten wie negative masse diese
So genannten polar addons erzeugten sie. Ohne kühlung steigt dessen manipulierten sie, photonen des lichts, und
Kombinierten sie mit sehr speziellen kleinen teilchen den sogenannten e zitronen das ergebnis partikel die halb materie
Und halb licht sind manchmal auch als magic das bezeichnet also
so etwas wie magischer staub möglich wurde das durch
Ein gerät mit zwei speziellen spiegeln die einen optisch micro hohlraum formen die farben des lichtspektrums werden, aufgeteilt
und quasi
Angeordnet das licht interagiert mit einem ultra dünnen halbleiter aus molybdän
diese linie daraus entstehen
dann
Die polaritäten die sich ebenso wie negative massa verhalten bei der experimente lassen die fachwelt träumen von
Neuartigen laser, beispielsweise die kaum energie benötigen aber auch neue arten von supercomputern. Könnten mit diesem wissen entwickelt werden. Und
negativem asse gilt außerdem als voraussetzung für einen möglichen warp antrieb
Ja von dem science fiction fans wie ich zum beispiel schon lange tot denn der theorie zufolge muss
Ein funktionsfähiger warp antrieb in der lage sein das raum zeit gebiet. Um, einen raum stift
So zu verändern dass sich start. Und zielpunkt näher kommen konkret muss. Sich die raumzeit vor dem raumschiff
Zusammenziehen, und hinter. Ihm
Ausbreitenden da sich die raumzeit selbst überlegt schnell ausbreitet könnte das objekt dann in einer
Blase in einer art blase mitreißen dafür ist wie gesagt eine negative energiedichte wichtig ist könnte also sein ja es könnte sein wenn
Ihr also nicht zum bob antrieb, und allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet
meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp und den anderen messenger nur dann verpasst er kein video
Denn die abo box auf youtube die ist ja immer ein bisschen
Unvollständig dann erfahrt. Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Einfach hier draufklicken. Und zur begrüßung habe ich
ein kleines goodie
Und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks, um, social media abonnieren dafür erfährt, er zum
beispiel warum die video days ausfallen ja und nicht die
genau, die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken ebola erreicht millionenstadt mit der dramatischen entwicklung dieses ausbruchs im
Falls es verpasst haben solltet ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt da